after a long day of Bitcoin mining even
libertarians like to kick back with the
intoxicant of their choice and turn on
the TV here are 5 TV shows all
libertarians should watch
the prisoner follows a British secret
agent wants to walk away from it all but
ends up a captive of the very government
he once served late 60 psyckadeli a
paranoia long philosophical
disquisitions about the meaning of life
a series finale set to the Beatles all
you need is love it's all here along
with the charming insistence that I am a
free man this Netflix original series is
a bracing and long-overdue response to
decades of treacly depictions of
politicians journalists activists and
crony capitalists as motivated only by
principle and idealism the road to power
is paved with hypocrisy
and casualties
[Music]
hosted by the most memorable duo since
Cain and Abel [ __ ] trained a
skeptical eye on everything from bottled
water and feng shui to the war on drugs
in the death penalty never slow to fly
their libertarian freak flag Penn &
Teller didn't just debunk popular wisdom
they showed us all how to think more
critically especially about the things
we cherish most dearly
sadly the truth is not democratic widely
considered one of the greatest TV shows
of all time this Baltimore based drama
has been called a visual novel like the
best novels it explores and analyzes
class race and politics from multiple
viewpoints and perspectives different
seasons keyed in on different
institutions schools police the media
and the ways in which power was
exercised and abused often in the name
of helping the underprivileged
he's legalize drugs actually I elected
to ignore them he lost your [ __ ] mind
he's lost his [ __ ] mind
now in its 18th foul-mouth season South
Park is lampooned and satirized
everything from pompous Hollywood
celebrities to Al Gore's super serial
campaign against global warming to
murderous Islamic terrorists along the
way Trey Parker and Matt Stone have
taught us all real media literacy by
showing us how to identify and spot
phony philosophizing moral panics and
self-interested Crusaders a mile away
shoes off belts off sharp objects go in
the plastic train this is inhumane shut
up sir
so what do you think of our list I'm
sure we missed your favorite so go ahead
and please flame us in the comments
libertarians believe in free speech
first and foremost for reason TV I'm
Nicolas
[Music]
[Applause]